well uh chris the
titans were firmly in control of the afc
south and the packers firmly in control
of the nfc north
and uh they both ran into a little bit
of a problem yesterday let's begin with
the cincinnati bengals
four new offensive linemen due to injury
four of them
billy price pressed into service at
center price was a first-round pick out
of ohio state in 2018. he fell out of
the starting lineup this year been a
backup all season long price comes in
settles it down joe burrow raved after
the game i spoke to him when they pulled
the upset 31-20 zero sacks
by the uh
by the titans defense it has something
to do with the fact titans don't have a
great pass rush but still it's an nfl
team
and the bengals with a
patchwork offensive line managed to shut
them out and burrow is just incredible
his numbers from a yard at standpoint
were down but still he had 25 or more
uh completions in six of his eight games
he set the record for the most
completions by a player in his first
eight nfl games he's still on track to
set the record for
rookie passing yardage in a single
season that was set by andrew luck back
in 2012.
and uh you know chris this gets back to
a point that you've made in the past did
the titans let the steelers beat them
twice yeah well yeah there's definitely
you can certainly question that
but i think they got beat by joe burrow
legitimately yesterday i mean i do i
mean yeah you mentioned it cincinnati's
offensive line great job kind of
weathering the storm there as far as all
the injuries all that not a great pass
rush it even shines more of a light on
that i think for the tennessee titans is
a weakness and then the other thing too
is
you know when the pass rush was good
borough was just absolutely phenomenal
when there is nothing there or than when
the play breaks down you know to me
that's always the sign of a great
quarterback yeah it's easy to hit the
wide open guy four yards in the flat
whoa whoopty doo i could have got johnny
from the high school down the street to
do that what about when everybody's
covered and there's people around you he
just thrives in it i mean he really he
can be surgical yet he can be an
unbelievable playmaker that way and you
know gritty tough win there yesterday
certainly and you got to be a little
concerned with the titans yeah they made
some mistakes he had the missed field
goal tanner hill throws the interception
we're not used to seeing that but man
for a team that we i think both held in
that super bowl
you know upper stratosphere your defense
looks like that all the time it's hard
for me to start thinking you're a super
bowl team when joe burrow and the
upstart bangos are moving the ball up
and down the field like you like that
and uh the bengals going to their bye
week and they're feeling pretty good
about themselves even though they're
only two five and one and and i asked
i asked burro about
and it was just kind of a throwaway end
of the conversation
just like you know
what does this mean for you going
forward and you expect the cliche well
we would tell one game at a time
one day at a time from joe ohio
he said hey we have four or five very
very he went two very very very winnable
games
uh
well well i'd say i'd say four of them
yes or three of them at a minimum
because it's a
tour of the teams from the nfc east that
they have yet to play washington the
giants and the cowboys at the dolphins
is not going to be a cupcake and and to
start this stretch of four or five very
very winnable games at the steelers
that's not very very winnable but they
got two weeks to get ready for it and
this is their opportunity
to send the same kind of message that
they sent
yesterday
chris that was one of my best bets i
looked at titan's given five and a half
and i thought somebody out in vegas who
set the line must have been drunk or
something how in the hell are the titans
only five and a half point favorites
well they as usual they knew something
the rest of us didn't yes they did the
bengals uh look they i i'm not ready to
rule them out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports